oh my God
[Music]
Maddie Healy puckering up mid show
[Applause]
it all went down during 1975's concert
in Denmark Friday Maddie was in the
middle of the song robbers when he
locked lips with a man nearby the sage
[Music]
yeah making performances memorable is
nothing new for Maddie and according to
video circulating online he's been known
to plant the impromptu smooch guys and
gals alike but there's one special lady
whose rumored to have captured Maddie's
attention you never know what it's gonna
be Maddie and Taylor Swift were first
romantically linked back in May
following her split from Joe Alwyn a
source showed E.T last month they like
each other and are having a good time
hanging out Taylor has a crush on Maddie
and he thinks Taylor is awesome and
Incredibly talented I mean I think I
think I feel things intensely turns out
Maddie and Taylor first met nearly 10
years ago and were briefly linked at the
time but the 1975 front man denied there
was anything romantic between them
we met each other we exchanged numbers
in the same way that a lot of people in
this kind of world do and we spoke
occasionally and then
she's the biggest pop star in the world
I'm in Australia there's no like
relationship or or anything happening
it's just funny how people really really
bite into that yeah I have to understand
that like there are incredible perks
that come with this life there are also
really heavy pressures that come with
this life and you just have to try to
balance them well now it seems the
musicians got a thing for today's era's
tour Maddie was spotted at Taylor's
Nashville concert in May that's so good
in the pair was seen leaving an NYC
recording studio together days later all
that has fans speculating that things
are heating up between the two I would
always like to keep people on their toes
in that regard I think that's the best
way to be exciting though neither has
commented on the nature of their
relationship
[Music]